and now last week tonight asks how is
this still a thing this week
Iran how is she still a thing three
decades after her death the writer ein
Rand is still the subject of serious
debate and not just over how to
pronounce her name
Ayn Rand or on rondure however the
moderns pronounce it Iran not an R and a
and Rin ayan rands why I'm told it's ire
and mine ran became famous for her
philosophy of Objectivism
which is a nice way of saying being a
selfish why is it good to want
others to be happy we can make others
happy when and if those others mean
something to you selfish ran Illustrated
her beliefs in novels like Atlas
Shrugged and The Fountainhead stories of
rapey heroes complaining about how no
one appreciates their true genius my
work done my way nothing else matters to
me and if that remind you of anyone
it's probably someone like this until
I'm done with my Lamborghini entrance no
one's allowed it make sure they know
that because
I'm Rand has always been popular with
teenagers but she's something you're
supposed to grow out of like
ska music or hand jobs curiously though
brands popularity persists among a
certain type of adult
Mark Cuban how many times have you read
found three complete times you know it's
funny because I'll pick it up when I
need motivation but then if I read too
far I get too much motivation and I get
too jittery so I've put it down yes
unbelievably Mark Cuban's favorite book
is about a misunderstood visionary who
blows things up when he doesn't get his
way Kuban even named his 287 foot yacht
Fountainhead because sometimes having a
287 foot yacht just isn't enough to warn
people you're a douchebag and rands
influence extends even further Iran more
than anyone else the fantastic job of
explaining the morality of capitalism I
am a big fan of Iran and read all of her
novels and let me encourage any of you
who have not read Atlas Shrugged to go
tomorrow by Atlas Shrugged and read it
however I'm Rand is an unlikely hero for
conservatives because she was also
pro-choice a man who
friends to defend rights and objects to
the right to hell abortion that's not
the center of rights and anti God I am
against God for the reason that I don't
want to destroy his no not that one the
real God what do I think of President
Reagan the best answer to give would be
but I don't think of him and the more I
see the less I think and in case that's
making you start to fall for her take a
listen to her views on Native Americans
i pronouncing that they had any right to
live in that country merely because they
were born here and acted and live like
savages
why would conservatives hold up as their
idol someone who says things like that
especially when there are so many other
advocates for selfishness they could
choose Mike Donald Trump part of the
beauty of me is that I'm very rich or
drakes I'm worried about me
you're basically anyone on Bravo all of
which is enough to make you wonder Iran
how is she still a thing